think about the the psychology of a
person who decides to be a truck driver
there's something about the freedom of
driving a truck around the country right
so that person is already wired to be
kind of like an entrepreneur someone who
loves them and creates this Freedom
Cloud trucks which is based in San
Francisco helps truckers especially
smaller owner operators to manage their
operations four Cloud trucks started a
truck driver would go on something
called a Load Board they would find a
job that they want to take and then they
would call a broker manually right so
actually call this broker and negotiate
with this broker to figure out uh what
the right price is that that they should
book this load for and you you can
imagine that in this negotiation the
driver is at a disadvantage they're on
the road they are not in front of the
computer so they don't really have the
data to know what's going on in the
market in real time with Cloud trucks
not only are they searching multiple
sources at once so you don't need to go
you know search by search by search and
these different platforms you have one
platform where you're doing this search
but we also tell you hey in this current
time here is what we we believe is a
fair market price for this load so
you're negotiating with confidence
we had started cloudtracks in 2019 prior
to Cloud trucks I'd worked with Savannah
and Scotty and that was my first
exposure to the trucking industry and
learning some of these problems that
truck drivers faced and we had spoken
with local carriers and learned some of
the pain points that they face in to us
we knew that there were these were
really tangible problems that we could
use technology to solve so one piece of
it is the search side of it making sure
that all of this is integrated and
aggregated and another piece of it is
something we call the schedule Optimizer
where we're recommending these jobs that
they should take to maximize their
revenue we do similar things as well
with other parts of the problem so with
cash flow for example we've built
something called a CT cache where we're
able to pay these drivers instantly
after they complete a job as opposed to
having them wait for 30 days or 45 days
to get paid and recently we launched a
CT credit where we're actually provide
writing a credit card to the truck
drivers that work with us as well
Joanna grew up in Nigeria where his
parents had a soap Factory after he
moved to the U.S he worked at zenefits
an open door then he found itself
driving car startup Scotty labs in 2019
he sold Scotty to doordash I come from a
family in Nigeria that's entrepreneurial
and my my parents own a manufacturing
business back there and I worked there
for a year actually before I moved out
to the states for college 15 years ago
or so I've always been interested and
attracted to very traditional Industries
and Manufacturing and trucking are very
closely tied but before I started Cloud
trucks I started a company called Scotty
Labs where we were building autonomous
driving technology for the trucking
industry so I was spending a lot of time
talking to truck drivers understanding
their pain points and over over the time
running that company I ran it for about
three years before it was acquired I
came to learn that a lot of truck
drivers wanted to be entrepreneurs I
think what we learned is that
um a lot of
a lot of uh truck drivers the company
drivers wanted the owner operators
because they want to determine where
they get to go when they get to go there
when they're on the road when they're at
home with their families right and a lot
of the entrepreneurs just need more help
to be able to manage their business more
profitably so the impact that we're
seeing is if if we do our jobs right and
we continue to build out the very best
software to make it very easy to operate
a trucking business the owner operators
that exist today who are primarily the
people that we work with will be more
and more successful we have EI products
that allow drivers to really have Data
Insights on how their their business is
performing to get a picture of what's
going well how can they improve and how
are they tracking against their
financial goals and then along with this
we have our schedule Optimizer which
just makes it easy uh which makes it
easy for drivers to plan out Revenue
maximizing schedules over periods of
time so instead of searching for
independent jobs or searching uh day in
day out they can put in their
preferences and we will generate a
revenue maximizing schedule for them
with 142 million in Venture funding
Cloud trucks hopes to tap into the
nation's network of 3.4 million truck
drivers they're large Trucking
communities on Facebook they're large
large Trucking communities in every
single state that you go to and just
going out and talking to people and
really hearing from them it's pretty
obvious that they want to be
entrepreneurs because they want to earn
their time right they want to determine
when they're going cross-country and
when they're spending time at home I'm
not saying that every single truck
driver wants to be an entrepreneur but
certainly it's something that's that's a
key part of the trucking industry so
we're we're constantly listening to
feedback to really understand the pain
points our drivers are facing and this
is feedback across multiple channels so
our social media channels as well as
feedback we hear from conversation with
our sales team and feedback they submit
directly from the app and for example a
recent piece of feedback that was acted
on was actually drivers preferred to
submit preferences in terms of regions
as opposed to having to like
specifically submit specific like states
or cities and that was like what we had
thought of as an engineering team and so
we kind of quickly acted on this
feedback and built a region-based search
and region-based preferences and were
able to kind of ship this and so this is
this really embodies a spirit of
customer feedback of customer focus and
continuing continuing to iterate and
build uh towards solving the problems
our drivers are facing